despite the secrecy despite heavy
security a surprise visit to kharkiv
ukraine's second largest city is for a
leader who was at the very top of
russia's kill list at the start of the
war at the very least a calculated risk
president vladimir zelinsky personally
surveying the damage made it clear it's
never too soon to begin rebuilding
teaching
we have to find some money and credit
lines the state must provide guarantees
and cities must find super projects and
find the money because in the cities
governors and mayors are more likely to
find one or another european program for
housing construction some state programs
and some local programs
this is a chance a chance to give a new
look to such districts
he even went to the front line to
inspect ukrainian positions and met with
soldiers stationed in and around the
city
handing out awards and service medals
i want to thank each of you for your
service you risk your life for all of us
and for our state thank you for
defending the independence of our
country take care of yourselves glory to
ukraine
a trip meant to project strength and
raise morale to a place that is still
very much a front line in this war
a third of the city remains in russian
hands and areas not occupied by russian
forces come under regular attack
just hours after he left there were
missile strikes on the city
the ukrainian president has won
widespread admiration for his wartime
leadership at home and from allies in
the west
which he is hoping translates into more
long-range heavy weapons
and
zielinski's first visit outside the kiev
region comes as russian forces continue
to pummel cities in the east and south
as part of the russian forces objectives
to try and consolidate as many gains as
possible in the donbass region and as
ukrainian forces plan and prepare to
mount counter-offensives to try and
stall and possibly push back what has
been an unrelenting russian advance
zayn basravi al-jazeera kiev